all right drew we have an iconic piece
of american pop culture at this desk
right now look at this
the thigh master
right
oh god
dude it's harder than i remember it
being i i like that's a lot of
resistance
[Laughter]
well you remember these you guys you
remember you couldn't swing a fish
without hitting these in the 90s and
then i got fish
and peter would swing a cat whatever
people oh my god i mean now i'm really
like going for the clown thing
it just got a lot worse okay let's try
it
okay let's sit let's sit and i'll tell
the story okay okay
oh that burns okay ooh i oh okay will
people report suzanne summers just
revealed how much she actually made on
her thigh master empire here's her quote
she said they were 1995 times 10 million
you do the math and then actually it's
15 million of these were sold and that
adds up to about
300 million dollars you guys
oh this really does do something though
i mean i'm gonna have to i know my body
is sort of in shock right now that i'm
paying attention to it
can i stop
i just i love her out so much
what oh my god
oh
my god
is that real
is she moving
that's really hard
look she blinked oh
my gosh oh my god susie this has summers
okay
be careful
be careful with the way you have it
between your knees for us do you want to
get a soprano is it pointed the right
way
no
that is somebody around oh my god this
is so weird that you're here i can't
even okay let's act like oh my god
oh that oh that's easier now that's
better yeah i
i love you so
much you are such a natural treasure i'm
so excited to be talking to you you did
not i can't believe it
i had no idea also
not only have you brought so much like
depth at to chrissy snow and comedy and
effervescence but you are one smart
business hello
oh hello okay but what you said about
the money there are a lot of expenses
and you had to have them manufactured
shipped developed you know so yeah it
sounds better than it is but i did i did
great and it was kind of a
nana for me because i i don't know if
you recall but they always said she left
the show i didn't leave the show i was
fired because i my contract was up and i
was asked
all the men were being paid 10 to 15
times more than me so i went in and said
i'd like you to pay me what you're
paying the men and they fired me so that
no other woman
[Applause]
and then
look what you did you know i love that
you never let anyone underestimate you
and if they do you show them with 300
million dollars that's what you do
and changing the world yeah thank you i
mean thank you what gave you like the
idea or the path to take this on because
you've
definitely been really early to the
health and wellness game far before it
was on trend and was it always something
that you are passionate about in your
life
here's what i've learned
i i i celebrate my age i'm 75 now and i
love being seven o'clock oh my god i'll
tell you
here's here's what i learned the worst
things in your life can work for you if
you choose it like judo using forward
energy to win so you know being fired i
then
started as an entrepreneur and and did
really well and it was all because i
bought a pair of manolo blahnik shoes
that were almost 600 and i thought oh
allen's gonna think i'm so stupid and i
was in my bra and underpants and i put
them on and i walked out of my dressing
room said to alan in my bra and
underpants like my new shoes
and those ended up being the shoes that
i wore in the commercial
which i then got to write off because
they were free and they panned up my
legs and alan said great legs and that's
how that began wow i mean i also um want
to ask you one last question suzanne is
it true
that when you were getting you know
different sort of business opportunities
what
is it that you can suggest to us so we
may take your wisdom
you keep betting on yourself
what is your advice to us
you can't be yes like right now you know
with all the books i've written 27 books
and
all about health and being a child of
alcoholic and all these things but
i
when i was telling people the the the
terrible effects of chemicals on our
body that's been introduced in our
lifetimes and you can see the epidemic
of sickness and disease commensurate
with the chemicals so i developed a line
of organic cosmetics uh organic
skin care lead free lipstick household
cleaning products without you can get
them at suzannesummers.com
and i can sell it because i totally
believe in it i i think it's crazy to
put chemical creams on your hands and
arms and or face or body and then have
it drip into your bloodstream and then
end up in your gi tract and everybody's
got gut problems oh by the way
i have a thing called gut renew right
there
right there which is so popular
it's broadcasting the time after right
now i i ordered in lots of like 70 tons
at a time so i just kind of go with the
flow listen to what the people say
listen to what my gut says
and i've done real well with it and i
also have a partner my husband alan
hamill who i just adore i after we've
been together 54 years
[Applause]
[Music]
you